yemeni soldiers fire at houthi positions
west of marib
the houthis are trying to seize the city
the internationally recognized
government's last stronghold in the
north
their spokesman says they're only
targeting government forces
but residents dispute that
we call for an immediate cease of the
belligerent war against civilians in
mary
there are no military barracks or posts
in the city there are no
militants or fighters in marip it's only
home to civilians
students and displaced yemenis
yemen's government has been locked in a
power struggle ever since the houthis
captured the capital sanaa
in 2014. it's called on the people in
marib to help the army defend the city
yemeni commanders say they're determined
not to lose control of it
will always remain steadfast standing as
high as the sower mountains
by virtue of its brave men the men of
the national army in popular resistance
along with the honest tribesmen we're
all standing in defiance defending the
city
marab is and will always be the
heartland of our republic
saudi arabia has invested heavily in
marib in recent years
the saudi coalition has intensified
airstrikes
to stop the houthis from seizing the
city
[Music]
the upsurge in violence comes as the u.s
is due to lift its terrorist designation
for the houthis on tuesday
president joe biden the united nations
and aid groups
fear the designation is worsening an
already catastrophic humanitarian crisis
the un says four hundred thousand
children in yemen could die from
starvation this year
if they don't get help victoria gatenbee
al jazeera
hassan al-thab is the legislative
manager for middle east policy at
friends committee on the national
legislation he joins me now live
via skype from washington dc good to
have you with us on the programme
it does seem that the focus of the who's
the offensive is to rid the government
forces from their sort of last
northern stronghold how does this if at
all change the balance of power
in that part of the country
yeah thank you so much for having me um
the fight in marib has been going on
for about a year now and it's really sad
to see any violence in yemen escalating
and
it's unacceptable that civilians are
paying the price of these warring
factions whether it's the houthis
or the saudi uae led coalition and i
truly hope we can see justice and
accountability on anyone that's
perpetuated violence against innocents
you know i think it goes to show that um
you know there's much work to be done
you know on behalf of yemenis to advance
peace it shows that
you know the houthis have made an
immense um
you know they have a lot of momentum
militarily but you know the
international community needs to do what
it needs to do to support diplomacy in a
peaceful uh ceasefire negotiation
you know you talk about diplomacy but
where does this actually the saudis who
continue to back i believe
a beleaguered government under pressure
to resolve this very quickly
it seems the only way they can resolve
this is militarily and they're not doing
that very well if
if you take their position when the
houthis seem to be advancing
yeah i don't think there is a military
solution in in yemen
it shows that the coalition is failing
militarily uh despite
despite a massive power imbalance uh via
the saudi coalition's
air force and air strikes and then
inflicting maximum harm on civilians as
they have been for the past several
years
you know if the u.s exits and gets its
allies to exit as well
it will leave the saudis completely
isolated
biden on the campaign trail called saudi
arabia a pariah
on the international stage because of
the war in yemen and because of mohammed
bin salman's
ordering of the murder of jamal
khashoggi so you know six years of
waging war on yemeni civilians have been
completely unjustified and it really
like i said before it makes saudi arabia
even more isolated than they already
were
we are seeing a policy shift though
aren't we from the u.s
this is becoming what will be
problematic for the saudis when in fact
the u.s secretary of state only
mentioned a few days ago that they're
going to lift the terrorist designation
from the houthis how does that change
the equation
yeah saudi arabia you know for a long
time they were lobbying the trump
administration
to label the houthis as a fto or a
foreign terrorist organization
and it's not shocking that they are
keeping their
terror designation on the houthis in
place but
you know i should mention that saudi
arabia isn't delivering
any substantial amount of humanitarian
aid or funding
or doing you know work on the ground
and they've been using food as a weapon
since the start of this war through
their air land and sea blockade
that's choked off the flow of food fuel
and medicine
biden has lifted the united states
foreign terror organization designation
i believe tuesday will be the official
date
um and that you know i think that's
significant because that's going to
allow
humanitarian aid operations to move
forward and
and help protect innocent yemeni
civilians who are
you know millions of suffering on the
brink of famine
and again it makes saudi arabia even
more isolated as they perpetuate this
terrible war and blockade on the
on the majority of yemen's population
hasn't aldab it's good to get your
insight thanks very much for joining us
from washington dc thank you